crime où vous avez là c'est alors igor
c'est votre jardinier qui me l'a donnée
vous êtes très aimé
j'essaie simplement d'être moi-même
quand j'essaie d'être moi même les
chants la pression pour moi j'espère que
cette affaire'' urgente fait pas trop
préoccupante pour vous est-ce que berger
s'enfuient lorsque les loups
apparaissent
notre église prend une direction que je
ne peux plus cautionner battu pour
accomplir ce qui devait l'être mais j'ai
perdu
l'épave ne renonce pas en renonçant vos
porterait un coup terrible à la papauté
je ne peux plus m'asseoir dans la chaire
de saint pierre vous méprenez brieuc est
rien jeune je ne peux plus te dire ce
rôle
il ya un dicton dieu puis toujours un
pape en enfant au monde son succès sur
j'aimerais que ma punition arrive là
pour réformer
il faut être un politicien la qualité
primordiale pour un dirigeant c'est de
ne pas vouloir être dirigeant ce n'est
pas moi qui ai besoin d'être satisfait
c'est un milliard deux cents millions de
croyants
l'église a besoin de changement et c'est
vous qui incarne est impossible ça ne
peut pas être moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et un et figé dans la nature sans parler
de dieu où puis-je vous trouvez s'il
bouge tout le temps
au cours du voyage nous trouverons
peut-être dieu par là au cours de
voyages je vous le présente
un billet jamais ça n'est pas dieu pas
on fait que déjà
[Musique]